3d printing is a process that uses
high-tech machinery to turn a digital
file into a physical object most often
it's associated with industrial items
like automobile parts or medical
implants but one company in california
has found a whole new use for the
technology one where the d in 3d might
just as well stand for delicious our
jamie wax has the story
in the modern world we hear the term 3d
printing so frequently that it's almost
become meaningless
but at a tech slash culinary startup in
downtown los angeles 3d printing is
creating something very specific and
sweet a lot of these designs yeah like i
we have inspiration from chefs or just
we kind of have some crazy ideas in the
lab and we're just like okay let's just
make this
really fun food product sugar lab
creates small beautiful detailed
sculptures every one of them edible
creative director william who showed us
some highlights including some
custom-made designs special for our
visit like these cake toppers tiny bites
of a latte filled with ganache that was
a very complex bite i mean i've got
chocolate i've got peppermint and i've
got coffee flavor in here
but they're all sort of hitting at a
slightly different time and in a
different way yeah we love that kind of
bringing our you know customers through
that experience craft beer bon bons
incorporating various beers into the
filling the visual printing on these is
incredible we kind of took inspiration
from breweries to make really poppy
labels and then yeah with the shadows we
wanted to really emphasize the that
little pop top on top and they even add
an element of fun and sparkle to drinks
with these glitter bombs these are lime
flavored printed with edible glitter as
you can see it's melting there with the
glitter i mean that's just fun yeah
to watch much less drink that's just fun
well cheers to your creativity cheers
thank you like many revolutionary ideas
the whole thing started almost by
accident in the college department of
founder kyle von hassell who was
studying architecture i basically was
grocery shopping with my
wife and we brought home some
cake batter like in a box and we get
into our tiny grad student apartment and
we realized we didn't have an oven so
there was no way to bake it actually
and
we
we thought what would it be like to
actually use this 3d printer that we've
been using for architectural purposes
and pour in sugar could you 3d print
frosting could it could you make it
sculptural could you add color after
some experimenting his vision eventually
grew beyond the existing capability we
realized that the technology couldn't go
much farther unless we did a lot of
research a lot of homework and developed
a 3d printer from scratch which would
require a lot of innovation
a lot of invention that's when he
brought in co-founder and chief
operating officer megan bozeman
3d printing was the focus of your work
and your life at the time when you heard
about this application what did you
first think it's a market that had not
even been tapped into and the technology
is something that could deliver a whole
new product in a whole new way allow
chefs to be creative in a whole new way
to see that firsthand i donned a hair
net required around the equipment and
toured the sugar lab itself so victoria
this seems like an incredibly fun job in
the culinary world it absolutely is
easily the most interesting and
different thing i've ever done in-house
chef victoria johnson walked me through
the process of printing
some of sugar lab's delectable creations
starting with the computer design
i am
re-configuring these strawberries then
to where the magic happens at one of
their 3d printers i'll show you so
we got to get wow all this powder out of
here now i know where these are right
but i will show you you've done this a
lot so we've got one here
and uh i mean that that's it that's the
whole thing but of course you can see
it's covered in powder so we always give
it a little tap to get all the powder
out of the inside
that is that's truly surprising i have
to say it's completely wrong
the color the texture and everything
just rise up
that's amazing with the right blend of
business creativity and technology
sugar lab got the attention of the
culinary community how important was it
to involve chefs in this process uh it's
been critical the people that we asked
were pastry chefs they were our first
clients nobody
would want to buy these if they were not
delicious
and so the chefs really help us bridge
that from beautiful that's what the
architects really deliver to beautiful
and delicious and an experience that
people have not had before and
collaborations with chefs have led to
innovative and even savory uses of the
technology like top chef winner mae
lynn's 3d printed quail egg and las
vegas french chef yuri charcevsky's
hyper realistic honeycomb they see
something that they've never eaten
before and then they're surprised with
this
the filling that he's put in their goat
cheese mixed with other
ingredients that he then bakes and
serves and it's an experiential
meal for the customer the instagramable
nature of sugar lab sculptures have led
to collaborations with celebrities like
kylie jenner but kyle von hasslen still
sees a bigger future for the dream that
started in that college apartment where
do you want this to go i'd love for this
to expand across the country
into other countries an increasingly
urbanized united states where food
scarcity issues could come up being able
to have those local ingredients and
print with local 3d printers i think
could make a really big difference and
we want to make sure the technology is
out there and distributed wildly enough
that it can have that kind of impact for
cbs saturday morning jamie wax
los angeles
here we go take these diamond artists
it's like a little diamond glitter bomb
i know i love this
i mean i know she said that people
wouldn't want these if they didn't taste
good they're so cool that i think i
might the tasting good is the added
benefit oh this is the strawberry it is
so good okay
okay
but i just have a bomb as good you did
the strawberry i'm gonna do i think this
has like chocolate looks by the way
little tiny cbs saturday morning coffee
this is like made for me this is the
greatest that's the one a little spruce
i don't know that's the one can i just
say jamie wax and a hair net
it's a thing oh my god what so what is
this did you eat oh you want to eat this
there's chocolate oh my god
i think it's an espresso i know we were
sent it and marcy's going to kill us but
how's that minty yes very good